remember the struggles along the way are
only meant to shape you for your purpose
sometimes you need to get knocked down
before you can really figure out what
your what your fight is
and how you need to fight it
to feel the pain and sting of defeat to
activate the real passion and purpose it
is the reason you are on the planet at
this particular time in history your
very existence is wrapped up in the
things you are here to fulfill when I
dare to challenge the system that would
relegate us to victims and stereotypes
with no clear historical backgrounds no
hopes of talents when I questioned that
method of portrayal a different path
opened up for me the path to my destiny
when God has something for you it
doesn't matter who stands against it
if it's meant for you
I don't know what your future is but if
you are willing to take the heart away
the more complicated one the one with
more failures at first than successes
the one that has ultimately proven to
have more meaning more Victory more
Glory than you will not regret it
two little kids Ian and Taylor who
um
recently passed
from cancer I was communicating with
them knowing that they were both
terminal
and what they said to me is and their
parents said they just they're trying to
hold on
till this movie comes
to a certain degree you hear them say
that and you're like I got to get up and
I got to get up and go to the gym I got
to get up and go to work I got to learn
these lines I got to work on this accent
but seeing how the world has taken us on
seeing how the movement is how it's
taking on a life of its own I realized
that they anticipated something great
and I think back now to a kid I'm
waiting for a toy that was going to that
I was going to get a chance to
experience or video game
I did live life waiting for those
moments and so what put me back in the
mind of being a kid just just to
experience those two little boys and
when I found out that they
yeah it's it's it means a lot
why do you think it's important that
right now we see you know Black Panther
on the big screen anytime anytime is a
great time for for a Black Panther movie
uh you know if if they could have done
it 10 years ago it would have been great
they could have done it 20 years ago
would have been great you know on both
sides as Africa as an African-American
and you know seeing people from the
continent I see I've seen a divide for
my entire life I went through my phase
of trying to find Africa and not knowing
well which place am I from I know and
I've seen Africans who viewed Us in in a
particular way where you're not
connected right you don't know where
you're from and at the same time love
parts of our culture so there's like
this weird there's been this weird
dynamic you know I don't know the oral
tradition because I didn't grow up with
it you know for from you know if I if I
knew exactly where I came from growing
up I would have had an oral tradition
from that place right I I've never had
that so this movie in a certain way
creates a story that we all share
everybody is the hero in their own story
you should see yourself conquering
um you know the dramatic action of
whatever you're trying to do so when you
get the crisis you know you know how to
deal with it you should be able to do
that and there are people that come in
and help you with your story but you
have to be the person who who deals with
the conflicts that are in place even if
you pray to God God expects you to do
some things so I think
um you have to be that hero
during my Junior and senior years I
lived in a house off campus
at Bryant Street for those of you who
don't know what that means that's at the
bottom of the hill where the incline
gets real almost every day I will walk
the full length of the hill to Fine Arts
where most of my classes were carrying
all of my books because once you walk
that far on foot you're not walking back
home each of you had your own unique
difficulties with the heel
for some of you the challenge was
actually academics
you did your best but you didn't make
A's or B's
sometimes C's you never made the Dean's
List but that's okay you're here
on top of the hill
you and your family struggle to make
ends meet every semester of your
matriculation you had to stand in one
line to get to another line to get to
another line for somebody that might
help you you had to work an extra job or
two
your hardest struggle was social
some of you never fit in you were never
as cool and as popular as you wanted to
be and it bothers you so your social
struggles here became psychological
even though you made it up the hill you
carry the baggage of rejection with you
but you're here
or some of you went through something
traumatic you made it to the top of the
hill but but not without scars and
bruises
most of you graduating here today
struggled against one or more of the
impediments or obstacles I mentioned in
order to reach this Hilltop
we're completing a long climb one first
experience is dizziness and shortness of
breath due to the high altitude
but once you become accustomed to the
climb your mind opens up to the
Tranquility of the Triumph
[Music]
oftentimes the mind is flooded with
realizations that will for some reason
harder to come to when you were at a
lower elevation at this moment most of
you need some realizations because right
now you have some big decisions to make
right now I urge you in your breath in
your in your eyes in your Consciousness
invest in the importance of this moment
as is often the case those that follow
most often enjoy the results of the
progress you gain
I was on a roll when I entered the
system of entertainment theater
television and film
in my first New York audition for a
professional play I landed the lead role
from that play I got my first agent from
that agent I got it on screen audition I
felt like Mike Tyson when he first came
on the scene knocking out opponents in
the first round
with this soap opera gig I was already
promised to make six six figures more
money than I had ever seen
I was feeling myself
I was let go from that job
on the next day a cold a phone call from
my agent
they decided to go another way
the questions that I asked set the
producers on guard and perhaps paved the
way for a less stereotypical portrayal
for the black actor that stepped into
the role after me
as the scripture says I planted the seed
and Apollos watered it but God kept
growing
God kept it growing yet and still when
you invest in the sea watching it grow
without you that is a bit of pill to
swallow
a bit of pill
anybody that's ever been fired knows
what I'm talking about even if you
really don't want the job when they let
you go
it's like any breakup
you act like you don't care I didn't
need that damn job anyway but when you
have those moments alone you start to
wonder if there was a better way to
handle it and if you could have if you
could have handled it better maybe and
help your family and then before you
know it you're broke and you find
yourself scraping together change just
so you can ride the subway so that you
can get the next job and maybe if you
could book something else that would
eclipse the feeling of doubt that's
building but it seems like you can't pay
them to hire you now and I definitely
didn't want to be caught dead going
after a fake Hollywood pipe dream I'm
more of a writer director anyway so
forget their stories I can tell my own
stories how would I maneuver through all
of this
finally I thought of Ali
in the middle of the yard
it is Elder years drawing from his
victories and his losses
at that moment I realized something new
about this the greatness of Ali and how
he carried his crown
I realized that he was transferring
something to me on that day
he was transferring the spirit of the
fighter in me sometimes you need to feel
the pain and sting of defeat to activate
the real passion and purpose that God
predestined inside of you
[Music]